What about CRISPR and what do you think,
uh,
is going to come out of that in terms
of like real world application for an
adult? I mean, what if people
don't know what Crispr has?
Please explain it in
layman's terms. A, yeah,
so CRISPR is a term actually was
invented in, in my department, poly.
So I know it pretty well.
It's a back bacteria,
have an immune system that cuts
invaders, cut their DNA. Uh,
and what we've done now as scientists,
we've now utilize that a system,
take it out of the back to you and we
use it to create designer mutations,
designer gene changes in
animals and also in humans.
So it's a bacterial immune system that
corrects genes and we use it all the
time. Now. It's, um, it's,
it's actually what's interesting about
us being able to mutate genes for many
years.
But this is dial up a gene mutation.
You can choose exactly where
you want to make it. And, uh,
so I think many of you listeners will
know that recently, uh, late last year,
Chinese researcher in our field came
out and said he's engineered a couple of
twin girls with CRISPR to be
resistant to HIV AIDS virus.
Wow.
Um,
if they're telling you that you got to
think they're doing some stuff and not
telling you about right, well yet have
some kids with giant heads and well,
it's coming through walls realigned. Well,
yeah. If you start to see people, uh,
that are 90 and uh, and they
still as young as 20, you
know, something's going on.
Yeah. That's the weird one,
right? If you can, you, you'd
go, Hey, what are you doing?
Nothing to Seton healthy looking
good. Take care of bots. Right?
They're not going to tell you. Yeah,
yeah. Well, so consider this, that, that,
so the chance of getting HIV
in China is one in a thousand.
So that doctor was seemingly,
he thought he was ethical,
protecting the babies from something.
That's, I would say really rare.
Whereas if he really wanted
to do something helpful to
those kids and we agreed
it was,
it was something you should do,
why not make them resistant to heart
disease or the cancer? We can do that.
It was weird that he chose
HIV as the first test. Why
do you think they did that?
Um, I think because it was a very
well understood mutation that would,
if you've just destroyed the gene,
it would work.
Whereas with these other diseases,
you have to be much more precise.
But the reason that we scientists got
really upset was that he did it in secrecy
and then just low launched it on the
world and that kind of thing because the,
it's a fine line and ethics,
you want to be doing that with
total transparency running,
I think he was hoping to become win a
Nobel prize or be a star and it backfired
on him because he,
he just did it in secrecy.
It backfired in the scientific
communities. Absolutely.
In the, in the real world.
In the media, I was shocked.
Help little discussion there was,
if this news came out in the two
thousands during the Bush era, it would,
there would have been panels,
investigations that would have been
in the news for months, but it wasn't,
people went,
Ahhh,
what's next on Twitter do you think is
just because the news cycles. So insane.
I do. Yeah. Um,
when you have a scientific
experiment of that nature,
what's the standard
protocol for a scientist?
Whether it is or is it the same in China
and in Russia and the United States as
a scientific community almost
operate under different,
like a different set of
rules and anything else?
You mean between countries?
Yes. I mean, you know,
like obviously technology is not shared.
Like China is doing
something technologically.
The United States is, we have to
speculate, we have to figure it out.
But when it comes to medical science,
is it sort of an open book because
everybody's sharing information? Uh, no,
or at least,
uh,
alerting everyone to what they're working
on or I know where you're going with
this. Um, at least I think
I do. Okay. Uh, yeah.
So I advised governments around the world
about what's going on under the radar
as best I know.
And there all countries,
I'm not going to name them that are
doing research under the radar and are
preventing people like myself from
entering those buildings to have a look
what's going on. Yeah. So I'm sure that
what's going on in there is actually a,
a little bit broader
than what we hear about,
but I don't know how long is it
before and I'll say Russia, no,
I didn't say Russia. I didn't
say anything. Uh, no country.
I want to be able to
travel freely. Russia. Uh,
but oh, I said it. But in,
in, in countries where there
are different standards,
what's stopping a mothers who wants
to prevent the child from having heart
disease, which could kill
their child, you know,
40% chance versus one in a thousand and
eventually you could make a child that
could live 200 years. Once we know how
to do it, that could be the future.
Um,
there's always a concern that someone
is doing something that is beneficial in
one way,
but negative in another way.
And if everyone doesn't get
to examine the research, um,
it's very difficult.
Like if we wanted to in the United States
wanted to do something similar to what
they're doing over there, we would want
to have access to what they've learned.
Right? Uh, we would, and so generally
scientists share information,
but there are companies that
are government owned that
are very secret. Right? Um,
and or even private organizations.
And that's where it's a little
tricky and that's why we,
we scientists get really upset when
companies or organizations don't share
information,
especially in something this critical
and what's not really stated. But it's,
my belief is that one of the reasons it
was such a backlash against this CRISPR
design, a baby experiment, and
it really wasn't experiment. Um,
it's not just that it was potentially
dangerous and you could end up with kids
that have deformities,
but also that unless we do this in a,
in a measured manner under supervision,
there's,
there could be a backlash like there
was against stem cell research, uh,
in the two thousands. We
don't want that. Again,
we want to be able to do this
the right way this time. Right.
Is it particularly if something
goes wrong with those children,
one person can ruin it for millions of
patients. The jump the gun and, yeah.
So this we're, we're on the second
generation of Crispr. Is that correct? Uh,
terms of, uh, the editing tools, they've
become more, they have that there's,
there's surprisingly that there's lot
of different bacteria that have the,
these systems.
So we're getting new ones all the time.
Some that are more accurate because
you don't want what we call off target
effect.
You don't want to accidentally me tight
some Jane that's required for head
development. Um, and so yeah, we're,
I think in my department we were on
fourth generation, fourth generation. Wow.
Yeah. See I'm just going by a
radio lab. Podcasts. Yeah. So my,
my department's a fun,
fun department today.
And imagine they are in painting
all sorts of stuff. What he,
did you ever see the documentary Icarus?
Oh yeah,
it rings a bell. It's a Brian
Fogle's documentary on, uh,
the Russian doping program,
state sponsored doping program and a
Sochi the Sochi Olympics and how they have
this incredibly complicated system of
stealing the urine and putting it through
a hole in the wall and putting fake
year and back through it was really,
really amazing, amazing, amazing
documentary. But uh, details,
this incredibly complicated
state sponsored doping system.
I would imagine that with something
like CRISPR or some various new forms of
genetic editing,
that that's one of the things that
they're going to be looking into,
that they're going to be looking into
things that are going to enhance athletic
performance. Yeah. I mean,
you might need to have a DNA test to see
if you've put one of these viruses in
your mind, why you 50 and now you're
running like a 20 year old, right.
So that's all possible, you know?
[inaudible] I also write reports for,
for governments and one of the things
that I predicted 15 within the next 15
years was CRISPR being used to engineer
the human genome and make a baby.
I didn't realize it was going
to happen within one year. Wow.
A lot of these technologies that I'm
trying to predict happened way faster than
even I think it can happen.
Do you think it's possibly happened in
other circumstances that they're not
going public with? Um, it's,
it's always possible. Um,
there may be some human clones running
around right now that we don't know about.
Do you think so? It's certainly
doable. Scientifically.
There might be some rogue nation who's
doing it, but Barbara Streisand's togs,
we're uh, we're pretty easy to clown.
Yeah. The, she had her dogs cloned, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Sammy, the 14 year old
dog is now, there's two of them. Um,
Jesus Christ, it is so weird.
That'd be like, I'd be so scared.
I go to sleep and wake up that thing.
It'd be hovering over my face was red.
Glowing eyes. Yeah. Wait till you have
design it cemetery. A friend of mine,
Carlos Bustamante at Stanford.
We're entertaining the idea of making
dogs live longer, uh, genetically.
So why would you want your family
member to only live 12 years?
I think about that man. My dog is only
two and he's such a sweetie. You know,
I'm sad that one day. I mean I had to
put my other dog down recently and uh,
who's 13 and he's just really,
there was a massive two and he was
struggling and I just think, man,
this two year old, one day he's going
to be in that same sort of situation.
Well it isn't.
And so we have three dogs.
My wife runs a therapy dog and
[inaudible] had her beloved dog.
Samantha cloned that crazy bitch.
Look at her two copies of it. One Dog,
Jesus Christ. That's so strange. How
about just get a new dog? You fucking nut.
Ah, well so we might be nuts
in my household because we're,
we're giving our dogs and amen. Oh,
and how's it doing? How old is the dog?
What? The oldest dog is nine and he's
still doing fine. Does he look different?
My wife says, so these are anecdotes.
I'm not going to publish them, but uh,
so Alice has a therapy dog and he has
to go to hospitals and nursing homes.
And if he has any men,
according to my wife, uh,
he can't be a therapy dog because
he's too excited. He's running around,
jumping around really? So
that, that's anecdotal, but
that seems to fit with what,
uh, others have
experienced too. Wow. Yeah.
So what we're hoping to
have some treatments for
some pets are shortly one of
the companies that I'm working
with treatments for pets. Yeah.
Well you gotta thank, Hey man, dogs aren't
going to live 13 years anyway, you know?
Well,
yeah.
And also we have a dog that has a kidney
defect and the vets is only going to
live five years, so she's three now.
So that's the one, your experiment,
what we experiment on,
on, on all of them. But,
but what's the downside that's gotta
be so uncomfortable for some people
listening to this right now. Like, oh, I
don't know how to feel about that. Right.
What is the downside?
If your dog has got a kidney defect and
it's only going to probably live to be
nine, meanwhile the dog's going to
live to be a thousand years old. Well,
we'll say, I'll come back and I'll,
you know, in the Lotus position,
meditating a hundred years from now, what
do you do if it starts talking to you?
That'd be great. Yeah. What?
What do you do if you turn a dog into
some new kind of thing that lives 30 or 40
years? What do you do? You
tell people, like if your dog,
like right now you're talking about on
the podcast and a bunch of people are
probably going to remember it,
but a lot of people for yet,
but if like 1520 years from now,
your dog's still chasing balls and
people are going to come over your house.
Hey Dave, what the fuck's going on with
your dog man? Right. Dot. That's Charlie.
Yeah. How come Charlie doesn't
have gray hair anymore? Man.